a pro-abortion rights rally was held
downtown right in front of our federal
courthouse madison kimbrough was there
earlier tonight and spoke to organizers
and state leaders about the impact
[Music]
stop
trying to tell women what to do with our
bodies alisa fast just one of many las
vegas locals who came out to tuesday's
band off my body rally held in front of
the federal courthouse in downtown let's
continue to stand up and fight planned
parenthood votes nevada hosted the
peaceful protest and says this will be
one of many if roe v wade is overturned
it's just
outrageous that what's happening now
right that
the precedent that was sent under the
landmark decision of roe v wade is not
being respected and so really today it's
about
being in solidarity as a community
hearing from folks who will be directly
impacted by this decision and several
state leaders in attendance shared that
this potential move by the supreme court
would destroy decades of progress for
reproductive rights amongst other things
they talk about freedom in so many other
ways but when it comes to someone making
decisions about health care and abortion
and choice now suddenly they think
government should decide other states
that are poised to make abortion illegal
and there are 28 of them about to do
that those people are going to look for
some place to go and they could come to
nevada we don't have enough doctors as
it is so it will put a strain on the
services we can offer madison kimbrough
live local now